Just five minutes out of a football field can make all the difference in a game.
And you know, just five minutes as a volunteer can make a big difference, too.
In five minutes, you can help feed a family, mentor a youth,...
...or help a neighbor cut energy cost.
I've volunteered all my life, inspired by the way Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. gave up himself...
...and serve the greater good.
We honor this legacy with the National Day of Service.
It's the perfect time to get involved and give back to your community,...
...whether you have five minutes or five hours to spare.
AARP Create the Good can show you how.
It's easy.
Visit createthegood.org to find ideas and information about ways to help in your own community.
No matter your schedule or interest,...
...you're sure to find a way to give back because there are opportunities every day, year-round.
Visit createthegood.org today,...
...and find out how a little time can go a long way.